see
it's good vodka penne my keys get a new
ballgame data but many of those new mojo
Cola he would go down man scale go to
there and met there because a cheetah's
tread water there are messy Sal bullet
to mark it doe special cover my sched
would be wrong I am NOT a gossip frenzy
over you both attest as a speeding car
tire I love my schedule
the whole purpose of it is to have fun
because sometimes life is really hard
especially for some of these kids they
go to school they have a lot of
challenges in their life and sometimes
it's great to just have fun we're doing
the best with what we've got there's an
abandoned warehouse here that we use but
it's really not that good it floods in
the rainy season but really these kids
they need a skatepark this city needs a
skatepark and this is our dream and our
goal that someday there will be a
skatepark in this city where the kids
can play safely and have a lot of fun